mary jane belliesa is live at manny's
ultra glow junko lounge with more on
that overnight mass shooting mary jane
sasha one man is dead and 13 others are
injured after an early morning shooting
happened here at manny's hookah lounge
located on sahara and vegas valley drive
now out of those 13 people two are in
critical condition i spoke to a 24-hour
bar in this plaza and employees say it's
a scary situation all around
at around 3 a.m saturday morning las
vegas metro police responded to 9-1-1
calls of a shooting at manny's glow
ultra hookah lounge in the commercial
center district officers responded and
found multiple victims suffering from
gunshot wounds
our officers did an exceptional job
immediately securing the scene
and rendering aid to include applying
tourniquets
and providing cpr
vince lopez is a bartender at spotlight
lounge in the same plaza he doesn't want
his face on camera but says his
co-worker was on shift when the shooting
happened co-worker told me about three
o'clock in the morning that there was a
shooting and he saw people running all
across the parking lot had a customer
that came in that was over at the hookah
lounge
and i guess he said he was an arm length
away from the shooter and saw him shoot
a woman
and he was really shaken up he had a
couple shots here and then after that he
left metro police says a fight between
two people or more led to the deadly
shooting a portion of the plaza remains
closed as police continue this
investigation our agency takes a lot of
pride in the fact that our homicide
section
has the best solvability rate in the
country
we do a very good job catching people
that do these kind of things
now police are still looking for the
suspects and police say if you have any
information about the shooting you're
asked to call crime stoppers at
you can 702-285-5555 anonymous as well
reporting live from sahara and vegas
valley drive mary jane balleza live
local now